what is your answer to the people who
accuse you of doing things like vacancy
Live Events with flares and who complain
about charging a lot of money for your
ce5 events
well actually anyone can do ce5 with an
app that took 20 years to develop that's
on all the stores so it's like nine
dollars or something so most of which
goes to the app developers and and the
Apple but so you don't have to come with
me then saying you do it yourself
um so that's just a ridiculous moreover
on the YouTube channel all that
information is there now the events we
do
um fund the disclosure project and what
we're doing
so I live on ninety thousand dollars a
year that's a big pay cut from 600 000 a
year as the chairman of emergency
medicine how much of a pay cut asks this
guy how much should pay cook he's taken
when other people take a 80 pay cut to
do this work they can then talk to me
um so otherwise just say thanks now the
reality is if you're going to run an
organization that has expenses you're
going to have to charge for things you
know and so this is one of these really
stupid questions in my opinion it's like
I have been advised that everything I'm
doing should be ten times more costly
than they are there's almost 90 plus
percent of everything we've ever done
has been done for free and is out there
in the public for free
um and that is not the way to build you
know financially an organization that's
taken on what we are this is why we
don't have any paid staff
or an office so in reality uh you know
we just did a workshop well it cost 150
000 with today's inflation to engage the
venue
and they made us buy all kinds of food
for the attendees and it was 150 000 so
I don't have someone saying we will
underwrite the cost of everything so you
can do these things for people for free
now maybe the person asking that
question is a billionaire who could
underwrite the expenses for all these
events and if he is great you haven't
given them a call otherwise in the real
world let's talk real world in the real
world you're not going to be able to put
on uh have an organization uh and do
something like the disclosure project or
if I have to bring uh some top secret
military whistleblowers in and it's at
my expense I do not ask the government
to pick up this expense where is that
going to come from my retirement savings
so yes there are fees
where the money can come from
oh really good yeah so again
um please Elon if you have a way of
getting free energy or you know someone
who who does you can set up a Bitcoin
Farm because one of the most costly
aspects is the electricity and then you
can fund
as much research as you like or at least
a significant portion of it so is there
are you looking into that is there a
reason that I don't have I don't have
one of those devices you didn't hear me
let me repeat it again we have
investigated and seen a network they're
all entrapped in a team of people the
inventor and his team that are wanting
to keep it secret
um now one of them that we recently
visited in fact was running Bitcoin
mining machines
man that's how that in fact there was
one little shed that it was in and
that's what he was using it for
he was mining Bitcoin so yeah so
certainly that could be done
um but I don't actually own or possess
one of those systems you know
I mean if we did that'd be the least
important way of generating Revenue I
think that there's actually uh billions
of dollars available uh from people who
do want to have an environmental
solution that would flow into any
operation that could widely uh prove but
here's the other problem if you're not
willing to open it up to Scientific
scrutiny it isn't going to be taken
seriously
you know all right so that's why like
with the disclosure project I say don't
take my word for it here are these 5 000
documents here are these dozens of
military Witnesses here's this now if
you have a device you can't make a claim
uh that's this Grand claim that it's
doing this and there's nobody who's a
third party entity that's credible who
has reproduced it or checked it so a lot
of times they want to go straight from
the invention to trying to monetize it
and there are all these other steps and
the the big one is the opens disclosure
of it open source but also the
scientific Recreation of it by
independent people who don't have an ax
to grind aren't trying to raise money so
that is something that always should
happen in science but that has not
happened properly with this because a
friend of mine who's a venture capital
guy he said there's a direct
relationship between how important the
invention is and how crazy the inventors
get so when you when you've hit
something like the gold the brass the
Golden Ring here and that it becomes
they become more and more direct because
they know what they have and they know
what its value should be and so with
that sort of bloodlust overwhelms The
Logical mind uh and this and the
scientific mind and they feel like
they're against everyone or to them
against the world in reality the whole
world would be with them one of the
things I point out there are a
relatively tiny number of people on the
planet that benefit from the status quo
of how the planet is running
but there's 99.99 or more of the
population that would be behind you if
you would open it up and disclose it and
then money ain't going to be an issue
because if it's disclosed open source
and it's proven by independent I mean
look if someone makes a claim like that
they put all the information out there
will probably be a hundred different
labs and people who will verify it I
mean if it's put out faithfully and
unfortunately a lot of these people put
out everything but the secret sauce
so I know I know a couple patents out
there like Stan Meyer did this where he
put everything but and he actually
falsified the voltages and the hurts and
whatnot of his uh uh electrical device
and that of course caused people to try
to reproduce and it wouldn't work uh so
I think that these sort of little legal
and financial tricks always end up being
counterproductive frankly to to what
their objective is anything that keeps
it in a small secretive group
um trying to monetize it you know knew
my analysis here's to my analogy
DARPA created what's something called
the internet not Al Gore but DARPA did
now that was done by government it
sorted let's call it open source
internet right get on the internet
the World Wide Web we need the
equivalent of that but it ain't going to
come from the government it's not going
to come from an academic Institution
we need the equivalent of a an organ
organization that's going to do this
research and development on these
Technologies in an open source way
that's shared openly and the technology
the platform the initial one I call this
phase one is widely available now that
would not prevent even if it's a private
Corporation from after that initial
launch doing very profound refinement
let's call it generation 2.0 or 3.0 or
10.0 of the device
um because that's how science goes
forward you know eventually uh most of
these early devices were rotary and
electrostatic rotary all four of the
ones that I'm talking about are solid
state
they're solid state no moving Parts
which is beautiful
yeah um some some guys in the audience
just wanted us to to just give it like a
high yes or no uh the question I
previously asked uh where someone
mentioned about dropping flares I just
want to check so you refute that claim
like no place
we've never done something like that
ever
now I do think we've had a few events
where
people have tried to trick us
and that's different uh what do you mean
where they've tried to Stage things
so that we'd be fooled as in
participants that came to your events
it's no outside yeah okay
yeah okay and and we've gotten pretty
good
at finding who those when that happens
but would you like to name each game
people like who like the government or
or the participants or what well again
the government which government
no the participants who come never would
do something like that
um but you know what I'm really
encouraging people is to people to get
get the app it's ce5 contact app and do
it themselves you know I got a great
report recently from uh truck driver in
Croatia who was driving along and doing
it took a break of and was doing the ce5
uh techniques and this uh ET crap
materialized to the left of his cab and
floated right over the cab and vanished
and we're getting reports like this from
people all the world so I tell people
you don't have to be with me I think if
anything uh due to the fact that there's
a lot of reconnaissance around what I'm
doing you're probably better off if I'm
not there
um I do like teaching people the
concepts and the techniques
of remote viewing and the meditative
techniques and what the cosmology is
that we're engaging uh and to me that's
like we're a big part of this needs to
come in is a whole revisiting of the
cosmology that it you know takes it out
of straight-line Universe
um because we're not dealing with the
straight-line universe we're dealing
with a Quantum holographic conscious
universe and uh that's a that's a very
different kettle of fish when you start
dealing with civilizations who certainly
understand that and their Technologies
are utilizing aspects of them
so um to me that's really exciting I
like it's still the thing that I love
doing the most actually but
um but you know there's a limit to how
much time I can take to do those so I'm
encouraging other people to do it and
you know it's not difficult to do
actually
is the is the app 100 required or are
there other methods that people can use
well if you don't if you know what
you're doing you don't need the app if
you are trying to learn about it get the
app there's like a smoker essentially
like a bit of guidance
oh yeah it's a whole it's like a
meditation I'm happy like just like some
people don't know how to meditate
they're like just get an app and like no
it's more than that it's like how do you
set up the group what equipment do you
have what you know how do you different
satellites from other objects no it's a
whole training program